boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sakyan we
are still on site at AAA the American
anthropological association's annual
meeting very excited to now be sitting
down with Dr Duncan Earl thanks for
coming onto the show thank you for
having me really appreciate it really
looking forward to our conversation good
let's give a background on Duncan
he's a professor and coordinator in
Global Studies at Marymount California
University for the last eight years it's
focused on global development rural
community livelihoods resilient culture
and sustainability
prior to that eight years associate
professor at University of Texas El Paso
three years associate professor at Clark
University and also associate professor
at Vanderbilt Texas A M and Dartmouth so
it's been 35 years of professing and
teaching wow
PhD in anthropology from State
University of New York at Albany he's an
author he also has had 50 plus
Publications a book is called uprising
of Hope accompanying the zapatistas on
their journey of sustainable development
and he's also works as an editor for the
Library of Congress and an editor for
Middle America ethnography and co-editor
of the University of Texas press border
series
and he is
students are currently involved in
applied sustainability research with the
Port of Los Angeles as well as with a
global carbon offset initiative jadora
to support large-scale rainforced
preservation and sustainable Community
Development in the Congo Basin really
excited to talk about that carbon offset
program that's going to be really
exciting and
yeah that's crazy it's 47 million
hectares that are the some of the
largest rainforests in the world that
you're working I'm really excited to
talk about that I'm super excited to
talk about just you know 35 years of
research and professing and yeah let's
let's jump into it but I but even before
we get into what's going on now Duncan
let's hear about you as a kid okay how
the heck did you get involved in
anthropology
well I did have a leg up in that
I was a large family that was raised in
the countryside in Upstate New York
right next to the the Onondaga Indian
Reservation
so I went to high school with about a
third of our school was Jordan Nash they
call themselves part of the Iroquois Six
Nations a third of your school growing
up was a Native American tribe yes whoa
yeah so we had the best lacrosse team in
Upstate New York needless to say and we
were very integrated and it wasn't it
wasn't a segregated situation because
they were an integral part of our
community our rural community
and my father who was a professor of
landscape architecture at Syracuse
University
he had been a kind of a bum artist in
the 30s in Mexico
and it was got it was part of the
muralist tradition of Diego Rivera and
Cisneros and them and actually worked as
an assistant to Rivera for some time
when he was painting the the Opera House
in Mexico City
so as a child we were regaled with
stories about Mexico and my father is a
was also a painter so we had all these
Landscapes of other places
and then at a fairly early age during
the Summers he started
driving there and camping in Mexico with
this whole family of seven kids
that's a big family yes whoa in fact in
1957 when I was five we drove in a
Volkswagen van all the way to Costa Rica
whoa and so every summer he did this
justifying it essentially is
is a visual material for his classwork
he dragged us all through
my gosh by the time I was a
Junior sophomore in high school
I'd probably been to 60 countries in
four continents mostly camping
that's a lot of culture exposure at a
young age that's great and then I went
back to my little home you know insulin
little Hometown with half Indians and
half rural
farming farmers
um
and then when I was a junior in high
school my parents sent me on an exchange
program and I lived a year in Barcelona
where I learned to speak Spanish
and really learned to have an
appreciation for my hometown in a way I
previously hadn't
Because by the time a year of living in
Cosmopolitan Europe come back to this
little town you go wow this is like a
like a novel about you know The Last
Picture Show
so uh it gave me a very kind of
Cosmopolitan preparation for school
then I went into SUNY Binghamton which
was close by my home
I went close by rather than some of the
other
schools that had been accepted in
because my mother had recently passed on
and kind of was part-time taking care of
my family as well
and then
when my father remarried I ended up
involved in a summer Field School
that took me to um
Guatemala
to do archeology in Guatemala
and while I had traveled some again in
the Mediterranean I spent a semester in
Malta and a semester back in Spain
the summer Guatemalan experience was new
for me because
unlike say Egypt or other places where
the Contemporary people are very
different from the ancient people
in Highland Guatemala the Maya
that were employed
as workers on our archaeological site
that I was an undergraduate grunt for
but which I had I had an advantage over
the others because I spoke at Spanish
I could see the workers talking with
each other about artifacts and in many
cases their interpretations seem to be
better than our archaeologist who was
leading the Dig
so
I kind of left my romantic notion of
exploring the mysterious Ancient Maya
and said wait a minute if I want to
understand
the people of ancient times I'm not
going to be able to dig up ideas or
conversations
but I can learn the ideas and have the
conversations with the ones who are
alive now
and maybe that will illuminate more the
past
while I was transitioning from
archeology to studying the present
Guatemala had a serious earthquake 1976.
and suddenly thousands of people were
there without housing thousands more had
broken homes you know broken up houses
and or we're in in fear of having more
houses fall 35 000 people died
and I suddenly started to sort of shift
a little more towards
well I want to learn from them about
these
esoteric cultural ideas but I also
really feel like coming from a
privileged place in the north that I
should be helping
so I suspended or so I thought my
graduate research
to work for save the children
in a project that they had in Guatemala
and nine municipalities 103 communities
and we were doing things like
reforestation Community organizing
helping people improve their their
housing so they wouldn't fall down on an
earthquake
and at the same time I got invited by
the local Mayas to live with them not
with the Gringos not with The Expatriate
a group that I was working with
and uh
I was a single guy I was willing to live
in somewhat less fancy
environment to live with the local
people since we were trying to help them
I began learning their language eating
with them
going to the markets with them
and little by little I began to realize
from that why the aid programs were not
working very well
and it was largely because no one was
really asking the local people
we were focusing on housing for example
no one really asked the question what
does a house mean
we know what the physical object of a
house is and that's what we were all
focused on
but Mayan houses are not American houses
they have distinctly different meanings
their temples for the family especially
if the father is a shaman and the
mother's a midwife is in the case of the
household I was living in
there were also granaries
places where people store their corn
and they point out that corn needs more
babying than people
you know he said oh one woman said to me
oh my husband he can go sleep in the
cornfield if he's
been out at the party and doesn't make
it home
and I just go out and at dawn and put
his head on his head so his head his
brains don't fry in the Sun
but corn has to be taken care of
so we were completely misoriented
because we were thinking of houses as we
think of them as places to store our
stuff in our crash pad
whereas they were thinking of the more
as a
religious place and a place to store
next year's seed corn and
women
administratively kind of own the house
and the men owned the field so when we
were giving courses to men about
improving the how to build a house we
didn't realize we were teaching the
wrong people because since men owned
houses we figured those were the people
who would make the decisions about
houses
this was not the case men decide about
corn women decide about houses
and in the Mayan language there kiche
Maya the name for your wife is
which is your house owner
which had we known this at the start
yeah what if perhaps reoriented oriented
us but because these Aid programs sort
of commit to a plan before they really
know
much about what they're going to do
because they never have money for prior
research because who wants to donate to
Prior research to help
right how old were you here again early
20s early 2030s so you're so you're in
your early 20s and you're starting to
really discover that there are these
societal differences among cultures yes
and that really we kind of we kind of we
put we push some of our cultures on
other people and just assume that they
have our cultures whereas their cultures
completely different in the way you just
describe the difference in a temple
versus a crash pad a place for next
year's seed that is so interesting and
then and then you also bring up this
interesting point about with
humanitarian efforts across the world
it's really important to uh go there
understand the culture uh really get the
Nuance of the culture to know how to
most have the highest efficacy of
Distributing resources through that
place and many non-governmental
organizations use the excuse of we're in
a hurry or donors don't donate for prior
research to not do this and this is why
so often they fail
and I watched this fail and the more I
told them about this how this was not
working the more they marginalized me
right because this was a threat to their
livelihoods and their operations
and eventually I quit
and went on to live some longer time
with this Mayan family and
I actually was sort of an apprentice to
a shaman nice and really learned
although I didn't write my dissertation
about Shamanism or any of the
you know Carlos castanedian
characteristics of things I used what I
had learned as a
Bottom Rung trained Shaman to understand
why
Community Development was not working
in other words I learned from the most
what we might call the most esoteric
dimensions of their culture to see why
the most concrete efforts to improve
their lives materially
we were approaching them completely
wrong well there's an in a whole
different
sense essence of being when you're a
shaman in Central America or South
America than when you are a householder
in the United States yes completely
different completely different for
example we built model houses to show
them how to build a house that wouldn't
fall down on an earthquake because most
of their houses were Adobe
and these were model houses we tested on
a flatbed with pneumatic pumps
underneath that recreated an earthquake
I mean it was technically
Cutting Edge appropriate Tech as they
called it at the time
but what we didn't
take a note of at the time and I learned
through my
time living with the
people was that you don't
build
a house that anyone would ever live in
that is at a Crossroads which is exactly
where we put our model so everyone could
see it
because Crossroads are where the Spooks
hang out at night
just like they did in the Old South for
African Americans
and I don't know if you saw Oh Brother
Where out there that's how we learned
how he met the devil at the crossroads
right so this belief which is a common
one about where you don't want to hang
out at night there we put this model
house and on top of that Maya's view
their houses as temples as they say so
they have to follow they have to face
and follow the direction of the sun they
have to have their back to the east and
their face the door and porch to the
west to the West as it sets yes the
sunlight come in which in the rainy
season since it usually ends at about
four in the afternoon anyway you can sit
on your porch and dry out but only if
it's facing the West so there were
practical dimensions and spiritual
Dimensions yeah that match well they
made the model house facing the East
yeah which is the direction of death or
the sun in the Underworld when it's
coming back
so
I began observing that people would walk
by our model house and cross themselves
you know so I took my old Compadre up
there and I said Don Lucas
um what do you think of our model house
he says oh very beautiful very beautiful
for Gringos yeah
and I said uh well uh would you like to
live in a house like this oh no not
while I'm alive
and he said we have one house like this
and it's in the graveyard it's where we
pray for the dead so if you wanted a
model house for us to pray for dead
people this would be a great model
but to live in plus he never asked a
shaman for permission
it only cost you know 10 cents in a
chicken
to do the ceremony of permission to put
the house there in the first place and
so the the owner of the earth is really
going to be upset with his house because
we didn't ask for permission and it's
like a boil on his skin
did you end up etc etc did you end up
having
deeply profound spiritual experiences
with the shaman and oh yeah yeah so can
you can we can we go run through some of
those
okay
uh
one of the most amazing was there there
is a system of caves underneath a nearby
um archaeological site
in fact my article in this book
is about this cave
because usually
in mesoamerica ancient mesoamerica they
made archaeological sites on top of
places with caves like teotihuacan the
main pyramid has a cave underneath it
but in the highlands of Guatemala there
aren't much in the way of caves because
it's all volcanic deposition for a
thousand meters down so what they did
this is about 200 years before the
arrival of the Spaniards they built a
cave
and what's better about a built cave
than a natural cave is they tell you
exactly what they want a cave to be
because they've built it themselves
and this is still used as a sacred site
by the shamans today
and it's an archaeological site of 700
years of age that they're using right
now as a sacred site
and so we periodically in the right day
of the Mayan calendar would go and do
offerings in this cave
in one time when we went there were a
few tourists around
who ended up going with us into the cave
they wanted to see him as you know and
my teacher didn't mind showing a few
extra foreigners about
shamanic culture
and I was able to translate it and
explain things so while we're in there
what are you offering uh we're offering
incense co-pila incense just from a
special aromatic tree the oldest incense
in the new world also
um the resin of pine trees that are
tapped a certain kind of pine tree and
candles and flowers okay because the the
the
concept their concept is that we are in
one world and there's another parallel
world and in that parallel world are the
Dead
The Unborn and the great Heroes of
history
and other kind of powerful entities that
shamans are able to connect with contact
and sometimes employ what's beyond the
three-dimensional perception that we
have in this world yeah it's sort of
like this other world right here you
know we have this idea that when the
Dead die they may go to heaven hell or
to fertilizer but they're out of here
they're somewhere else the Mind concept
of the dead and mesoamerica generally is
the Dead are right here they're just in
another dimension that unless we're
shamans we don't see them
so and they don't eat like we eat what
they like is light
Aromas prayer
Good Feeling
which interestingly enough this is a
muscle it's like when you go and shoot a
basketball or you're an author or
whatever you're practicing the more you
practice it the better you get at it so
the more that you practice the ritual of
connecting to the dead to go through
this process the better you'll get at it
and the more you'll be able to
effectively communicate with what's
going on in that area and amongst the
Maya that Communicator the connector
between shamans and this other world are
a little dwarf
like spirit
called um
means White sparker or Like Flint spark
is the Flint spark guy and uh he looks
like a child he's dressed in a little
white you know a red red or white
uniform a little hat it has a little X
it's a sparker
he's danced in one of their ritual
dances they they reenact him and he's uh
so any Shaman has this little duende
this little Spirit who connects him to
this other world
it's also represented in his medicine
bundle so we're in this cave and with
our medicine bundles and our offerings
of flowers and candles and incense and
what are the medicine bundles well those
are the the the
um
when you're initiated is a mind Shaman
you get a
a series of 200 seeds
erythriana what we call the Mezcal seed
they look like Black beans but they're
bright red and they're poisonous so they
never fall apart or degrade
and and with that crystals and other
things that you find during your
initiation in other words it's like
um
all of these seeds and crystals and so
on are used to count out the days of the
Mayan calendar
so it's your counting bag in a way
because is there plant medicine used as
well oh yeah yeah there's herbal
medicines and there's non-ordinary
medicines and then which
um plant medicines are used
uh Mexican Marigold or tages lucida they
call pedicon it's a natural aspirin but
it works slower but it's more gentle on
the stomach
and 200 other plants but I'm just doing
that one because it's yeah where I it's
the first medical plan I learned saved
my life and I was got very sick there
anyway
um and The Midwives know about those
plants
the shamans tend to work in the
non-ordinary world and then the midwives
or people who deal with bone setting
they do all of the
physical healing because the idea
amongst the Maya is when you get ill you
need to have physical treatment you have
need spiritual treatment you need
sociological treatment who have you been
fighting with yeah
and you need sort of psychoanalytic
treatment
that illness is a total illness and
healing is a total process this is not
just a physical thing who are you
talking to what kind of a cultural
setting are you actually did you have an
argument with someone yeah you know are
you and your cousin fighting about land
inheritance after uncle
Uncle Jose because that's going to cause
lots of stress yeah so
um is this a majority of the kind of
like the 20s for you is this study and
then you also end up taking this into
the next couple of decades oh oh yeah in
fact I I
still do divinations yeah I mean I ended
up having to do a divination for a Hopi
woman because her husband was a Navajo
and they didn't trust either the navajos
or the hopies to do spiritual healing
whoa because they're in Conflict so they
brought me in as an outsider to do the
healing process and then is this a lot
of what you've been teaching the last no
no I don't talk about this in the
classroom at all interesting or in my
Publications
interesting because why because the Maya
has explained to you very clearly you
didn't earn this
you know all my Publications I earned
it's a hard research and so on but I
didn't earn my divining talent I was
born with it according to them
huh and they knew about it through
divining that I needed to learn this in
fact I needed to learn this that they
were going to throw me out of the
community yeah yeah because I'd be a
spiritual Loose Cannon and I might do
something yes I might whammy somebody
without knowing
something like that so it's been part of
my personal life it has guided my
anthropological life but I don't write
about it interesting I mean I talk about
it in a in an interview like this
because it's so much has influenced
other things of mine exactly but it's
really become a part of me not really
part of my research I've written a
couple of very humanistic articles like
about when we went to the first
higher Shaman than my teacher who
because I wanted a second opinion
because I didn't think a gringo should
be learning this stuff
and they took me to a possession Shaman
they're truly scary folks whoa but uh
back to the cave
we're in the cave there are these other
Witnesses and tourists from Germany and
and France and the U.S six or seven of
them
and then while we're doing our ceremony
we start hearing laughing children
the voices of laughing children and all
of us heard this not just me or just the
Mayan shaman
and his couple of his kids were with us
too
and we're going like there's some little
kids coming into the other end of this
200 meter long cave
and we hear them getting closer and
closer and then when they're just about
to come around the corner where we could
see them
silence
and
my
old Mayan compat that he turns around to
me and says
those are my Striker Spirits those are
my sake
they come to to
connect me you know sort of to connect
like tele telephone to the other side
right or the telegraph to the other side
and we're all going yeah no it was
probably a school group that came in you
know and then turned around before they
got this far they saw the smoke and
decided to leave
and so
the tourists fanned out over that whole
site trying to find young people
there was nobody there
we asked the guy who takes tickets at
the entrance no school group no children
have come here anywhere
and we're all left with you know
who were those voices we all heard those
voices those were the kids that helped
the shaman connect to the other side
they're like little miniature people
that fly around and help the shamans do
their stuff
and they're the ones that give the
knowledge to you when you're divining
because divination is not like about
what you know it's about how empty you
can become
it's how much you're not there so that
the non-ordinary guides are in
interesting so if you can
get past the ego that's so in control of
this this body right and if you can kind
of treat yourself more like a channel to
receive yes then you can really tune
into what is coming through so I
appropriated the shamanic vehicle to
understand my world Mayan World
especially better
but not as a vehicle for
tenure in promotion
not as a vehicle for writing up articles
that would get me a better job in my
discipline that seemed wrong
to me ethically
I feel as though even though you became
more spiritual and very understanding of
a lot of the shamanistic practices
I'm one of the
I feel strongly about the integration of
spirituality and mysticism with science
and individualism and collectivism and
so if we were to be able to strongly
merge those because that's why I asked
you if you were passing along some of
that to your students and so shall we
should we venture into some of the
some of the dissertation how did you get
from there to the dissertation so I
write my dissertation essentially on why
Community Development without prior
depth research is a waste of time and
money that was essentially my
dissertation but I thought I was going
to only do it on Highland Guatemala but
in the middle of that comes the
political repression of the late 70s
and I find myself having to flee
Guatemala
not only is my life endangered and this
is during as soon as Ronald Reagan got
into office here the repression started
happening there and what was the
earthquake 76 was the earthquake 76 75
000 people died but by 79 they were
starting to kill way more people than
died in the earthquake because of the
for political reasons they were looking
at El Salvador they looked at the
victory in Nicaragua
Ronald Reagan was giving them the okay
sign that we weren't going to worry
about human rights anymore
as we had under Jimmy Carter
and so they began killing large numbers
of of native people
in what they called a preventive
counter-insurgency
anyone who had been involved in
cooperatives or with the Catholic church
or anything that in any way was seen as
Progressive including development
programs like our own
were being targeted
in the end they ended up in about two
and a half three years killing
something in the neighborhood of 200 000
Indians
whoa mostly by hand
with machetes geez some they burned in
churches they put everybody in the
church and set it on fire
they did horrible things I lost about a
hundred of my friends
some of them were skinned alive
so I suddenly in the midst of my
spiritual situation got a real political
slap in the face and had to flee because
have seeing a a North American talking
to an Indian could lead to an Indian die
to iodide so I was one more time it was
a fight in the late 70s it was accounts
because they wanted to prevent an
incident there were some rebels in the
northern part of Guatemala who were
saying we're going to overthrow the
Guatemalan government and we're going to
get the Indians to help us do it oh and
the Indians didn't know anything about
it really most of them and there was a
few who joined the rebels but not many
and so the rest of them were all caught
in the middle
and I had to get the heck out of there I
I remember selling my typewriter and my
camping gear and everything I could to
give bus tickets to the community
leaders to leave the country
I mean and and I I got the last you know
took the last ticket and went on the
last bus out
uh and got to this
place in in Mexico called the state of
Chiapas which at that time was a very
quiet calm backward part of Mexico
and I came across while I was there
through a third party
a guy named Gary gosen who is a
professor from previously from Harvard
who was teaching at Santa Cruz
who was doing a research project in
Chiapas
and
I didn't really wasn't ready to go home
and he had a fascinating project of
looking at
Highland Mayas from that side of the
Border who had gone down to the
rainforest and colonized it and here was
a case a Counterpoint to Guatemala of
people who were doing their own
development
so it wasn't development imposed by
Outsiders who didn't know what they were
doing culturally it was local people who
were the culture that was doing it so my
dissertation contrasted how people when
they do their own development do it with
what happens when it's imposed from the
outside
and that was yeah a pretty passable 500
page dissertation and that's great
because you had an exact contrasting
dichotomy between when it is I mean when
you think you know what you're doing and
when you actually know what you're doing
and the difference between humanitarian
work in that sense and it was very good
that I was in a new cultural landscape
because the last thing I wanted people
to know that was that I was trained as a
Mayan shaman
because there are all sorts of different
positions on that even amongst the
indigenous people
right never mind the mestizos and the
government
so because some are Evangelical
Protestants some are reformed Catholics
some think that the Traditions are
brujeria or witchcraft
so it was much better for me to keep
that
unless I came across a shaman there
and they always knew but other than that
and they always kept its secret because
they understood
but it gave me great perspective to look
at this Pioneer group of people who are
mostly Evangelical Indian evangelicals
they were not
following the old ways
and looking at how they had created for
themselves a little Paradise because
they know how to develop themselves
given the opportunity and the resources
and the Mexicans have this idea of
agrarian reform that doesn't exist at
Guatemala where if you can Pioneer some
new uncultivated land after a few years
of doing it they'll give you title to it
and it's a collective title not an
individual title so this was all
fascinating and Mexico is a an
interesting contrasting place to see a
related group of Mayans I had to learn a
new mind language but it was way easier
than the first one because they're
closely related like say
Italian and Spanish
and then the zapatista uprising happens
but meantime I had written my
dissertation I gotten a job at Dartmouth
and I had moved from Dartmouth to
Vanderbilt and then on to the Texas A M
where I'd also become interested in
Community Development which had always
been a theme for me on the U.S Mexico
border
and I I liked the issue I had been on
the Mexico Guatemala border and looking
at border issues there now is on the U.S
Mexico border and contrasting it and I
really look like to look at what we
might call controlled comparison
contrasts where some things are the same
and some things are not the same rather
than all different
so I spent some time doing work with
these poor colonias we even out of Texas
A M built community centers for them
because I came to the conclusion that
the real help they needed in those
in those settings was Some central
location that they could get together
but all the time while I'm doing that
I'm also going back to Chiapas and
checking up on what's going on with the
zapatisas because I knew before there
was the uprising I knew these people
both those that supported the uprising
and those who opposed it
and one of those visits I ran across
this woman Gene simonelli who had
previously done work with the Navajo
with the Danae
and she's a fabulous writer like she
writes novels at the same time and I
said Gene how about you and I do
field work on everyday life of the
zapatistas won't it be like not talking
to subcomandante Marcos or the The
Luminaries of the movement you know this
was heralded as the first post-modern
anti-capitalist movement that arose but
that was all focused on their leadership
who had a very interesting alternative
theory that wasn't left and wasn't right
it was kind of what we might imagine a
kind of pro-peasantist position
and it arose against the North American
Free Trade Agreement right
and so that was all one level of it and
that's where most uh anthropologists and
political scientists and others engaged
I wasn't interested in that that was
other people's work I wanted to go live
in sapatista and non-sup Batista
communities that were in this apatista
region and find out what's the
difference between living every day as a
sapatista and as a non-sepatista Mayan
peasant what were your findings
well I found that everyday life amongst
this apothesis was it was fascinating
because
they have they have a belief in
consensus not in majority rule
so everything that they would decide to
do everybody had to every adult had to
agree to do
and so we would sit in on meetings that
would sometimes take three days to
decide whether they were going to do a
coffee dryer or a bread oven
but in that process they were learning
the process of
everybody being engaged in their own
self-governance
you know completely opposite of here
where governance is so distant from us
you know and good luck with that letter
to your Senator
whereas here people had taken on the
processes of governing at every level at
the Village level at the regional level
and at the top
based on whole levels of consensus
and they also were being very
positive to their enemies they literally
loved their enemies
they would have people who condemn them
for joining the zapatistas and then they
come leave them a plate of food
they they enacted the best of Liberation
theology on a daily basis love your
enemy you know your your uh turn the
other cheek uh we're all the same under
God
uh and uh
they saw in
these Christian teachings which one
could say were originally foreign to
them they kind of turned them into a
Mayan revolutionary document
so this was utterly fascinating to me
and uh
Gene and I wrote this book which we
wrote like a historic novel
with dialogue with uh you know character
development page Turner chapters and we
even put a chapter about each one of us
so that we wouldn't have the postmodern
authorial voice problem because we said
exactly why we were doing this
and we wrote it in such a way that a
freshman in college could read it which
were exactly the attitudes that we also
found that the zapatistas wanted us to
promote that this wouldn't be some
esoteric book that you need a very large
anthropological vocabulary to understand
but something that anyone
could read
I like I like that though we're all
children under God
that were all born from the cosmos and
here we are finding ourselves as
stewards of Earth and how do we work
together how do you love people that
yeah even if they have an opinion that
contradicts yours how do you work things
out through a consensus yep yeah and all
of this showed me a model of Community
Development that they themselves had
devised for themselves for an example
one of the great problems in Community
Development is how do you develop female
leadership
right if women have to run the household
as administrators
the reason why men amongst the Mayas are
the or end up being the leaders is the
women don't have the time right because
they have all these other
responsibilities
so what the zapatisas were able to do is
first get the men to get more involved
in taking care of things in the
household they would have these meetings
only with women leaving the men at home
with the kids so they had to do it
and then second they insisted that in
subatista areas they have male stores
and female stores
now these are just rural stores that
sell nails and boots and barbed wire and
tomatoes and
baby clothes
but they decided that they should have
ones for men and once for men and as
much as the
first world feminists didn't really get
this the reason was because once women
had stories of their own they developed
their leadership
yeah outside of the reach of men yep so
they didn't have to deal with male
insecurity about women developing
leadership because it was all women and
it turns out the women who were the
heads of these stores became very often
leaders yeah I would have never thought
of that that's what a run counter to
what we think about segregating men and
women yeah a segregation although short
term to reintegrate about women with
more power with more power that's very
interesting it was brilliant yeah and so
rather than be someone trying to impose
development on people as an outsider
with donor money I was now a student of
their own development
so you can see how this made perfect
sense for me
because here I was getting a lesson and
what happens when people really have the
power
to redesign their own Society for
themselves what would they do and they
had yes they had help from
non-governmental organizations and
international solidarity and yada yada
but the way they set up their stuff was
to solve the problems that they
themselves perceived
and so we wrote This Book on an uprising
of Hope because we thought here is an
example of of how people do it for
themselves and from which we could learn
great lessons
right what were the other great lessons
that you learned about how they were
building their society that we could
learn from
um
that the process is is as important as
the product
how you come to a decision about
something is really important
because you don't want people going
around saying well I was I didn't
support that
right because peasant societies they're
poor that they're very subject to
divisions and conflict
because
they're competing with each other for
you know scarce land and scarce
everything
so when you bring people together and
say we're not going to make this
decision unless you you all agree with
it
it's to us sounds very inefficient
but that long and laborious process
leads to everyone to understand why
anyone is making this decision
they all own it
when they're done
so the time that's invested in it the
immense amount of time that's invested
in making consensus decisions
is all medicine to their social
relations interesting so there is a
geopolitical
arms race that is occurring on the
planet that prevents us from allocating
the needed time to properly communicate
with one another to reach consensus
and that is a huge hindrance for us
progressing in a way that doesn't make
it feel like people are being left
behind yes yes and all the divisionism
even within our two political sectors
today
uh we don't have consensus within those
sectors and we certainly don't love our
neighbor across them
right so they're a great lesson to us
they have turned the tables on on our
political lives because they're showing
even us right now a better example
and uh not that uh everyone is reading
my book and understanding this
but they haven't lowered the price of it
on Amazon yet so somebody's still buying
it those are awesome lessons from the
book now give give us a rundown of the
okay the 35 years of professing now
as you've done that what have been some
of the profound takeaways from working
with students and also with some of the
lessons that you've learned that you are
teaching
well I teach a course for example on um
management for sustainability to
business students
the last thing you think is
anthropologists
teaching in a business school
but
um
if you really look at business
the people who rise to the top have the
people skills
it's not about numbers it's about
being able to interact with people
and second of all uh there's a huge area
arising in business
that if you want to get into it doesn't
have as much competition as regular
business it's what we might call Green
business or sustainable business where
you're being socially and
environmentally sustainable
my students get this very quickly now
mind you it's a Catholic
school so they're taught to be socially
responsible
and my pitch to them is to say imagine
you could have a business which improves
social life
which improves the life of the planet
and you make money
now don't you think that would take
market share away from a business that
just did what it did but doesn't have
any positive social or environmental
aspects and in fact might have negative
ones
I said so if you want to start in
business and be successful and take
market share away from
other less responsible businesses this
is how you might do it so I have four
projects that students are working on
right now
one of them is looking at how property
managers could be greener
and then compete better with other
property management operations because
they're green like those solar panels on
the roof and appropriate insulation so
that people go there don't have to pay
such high utility bills
Etc et cetera et cetera there's a
hundred things that an average building
could get better if it were Greener
awesome so one's doing that as he's an
intern in one of these property
managements and he has two other
students from my class helping them by
researching the competition and looking
at how to make a building greener
the second group is doing a Craigslist
for our community our our student
community and and alumni and so on so
that the community recycles internally
to itself
so you build community Through
exchanging goods within the community
through a a university-based Craigslist
that they have actually finished in this
term the third group is looking at
electric golf carts to replace cars in
Beach communities in LA and that's going
great guns in fact they have too much
work at this point they'll never finish
it all by the end of the term and that
may be a new popular
modality of transit in yes smaller
community that doesn't produce
greenhouse gases that uses less energy
generally and is more appropriate for
the environment that the setting that
they're in
and then the fourth one is taking the
ideas that I've been using in my Congo
project that we haven't talked about
on carbon offsetting and applying it to
Mongolia
I'd had several Mongolian students
previously I learned about their problem
of that climate change has undermined
the migratory patterns of their herding
so that half the herders are now in a
what we call in Latin America the circle
of misery around the capital city
and but they don't want to be there
they'd like to go back and raise animals
in the countryside but they don't really
know how to do it anymore because
climate change has messed up the
patterns
so their project and it's a project that
we hope to follow through on
is to figure out how we might through
through various Technologies
map in real time where the weather
patterns are operating
and get the herders to be able to go
back out on the land how do we pay for
that through carbon offsets basically a
lot of people don't know this but
traditional grasslands like the old
prairies in our west midwest
the steps of Mongolia
Kazakhstan Tajikistan and the savannas
of Africa which by the way are way
larger than rainforests absorb about
half as much carbon
when they're healthy
as a rainforest
mostly in their roots
in fact there's plenty of that going on
right here in California
but if they're undergrazed or overgrazed
they can end up producing carbon
so we have a financial incentive to
optimize animal Management in Mongolia
to pay for them to do it right that's
great and it can be done in such a way
that you can have investors who make
money off of this
the people who are doing it can can make
a profit at it and yet all of the people
who are working on it also benefit from
it so they're working on that project
right now and I'm hoping to go to
Mongolia in June
I got sixty thousand dollars for startup
to actually do a private sector project
of putting vast quantities of the
grasslands of Mongolia under
conservation for carbon offset purposes
yes so then these four projects are
um they're really powerful and they're
diverse and that that's that's great and
then they share with each other what
they find yes and it's good to have lots
of young minds working on the projects
and sharing like you said and being an
inspirational piece for other young
people to get involved in similar
projects so and saving the planet and
helping people yes exactly exactly what
they call the triple bottom line yeah
people plan it yeah people plan it
profit
now yeah because the planet we're profit
without people and Planet it's
ridiculous
Duncan tell us about j'adora okay
when I was between jobs uh
between my work and at Clark and out
here in California
I got called up by a former student of
mine from Vanderbilt
who's working for T-Mobile up in Seattle
and had he had a good friend who
has a business background and an
environment background
and he began
explained to us about this notion of a
carbon Market that there are markets
both volunteer and compliance markets
that pay for people to preserve
environmental services that absorb
greenhouse gases so you could get this
for example in California the yurok
Indians of Northern California
they had a big piece of reservation
filled with Forest but they didn't want
to turn it into condos
they didn't want to cut it down and sell
the wood but it wasn't providing them
any
resources any income
so the state of California calculated
how much those trees absorb in carbon
and pay them annually out of the out of
the California carbon Market to not cut
those trees down that's beautiful and it
comes in every year because every year
they've absorbed that much more carbs
right as a way of encouraging
more trees or more anything on this
planet that will absorb the Surplus
carbon and other greenhouse gases that
as you know we have way too much of in
the atmosphere the non-deforestation
initiatives and the carbon offsetting
initiatives right so this guy uh very
charismatic guy
um
also was love loves uh what we might
call charismatic megafauna he likes big
animals in Africa
and it doesn't yeah like who doesn't so
and was very upset about the reduction
of their ecosystems so that they're
dying out not just from being killed for
food or for their trunks or whatever but
that their environment is shrinking
and the last big place where the
environment has not much Shrunk the last
really intact rainforest in the world
and the second largest after the Amazon
is the Congo River basin
it's uh about two-thirds the size of the
Amazon The Congos the third largest
river in the world
and uh it's only about four percent cut
down
wow now sadly for all the wrong reasons
it's not cut down like bad development
no roads
abject poverty and ten years of war
but those people have been distracted
away from cutting it yeah it's cutting
it down and you know basically lack of
development that would have led to to
the Amazon solution
whacking it for cattle and for soy and
so on yeah so the only damage that's
being done is local farmers cutting down
slash and burn and planting very
inefficient plants there
so we calculated that if we could get
those Farmers to stop cutting down
rainforest for maniac and bananas and
and so on and get them to
plant those things on already cut land
with improved seeds and improve methods
and then in the forested areas to plant
coffee and chocolate which are way way
way more valuable plants
we could get them to become wealthy
while taking care of the rainforest they
would be incentivized to keep the
rainforest because they were making lots
of money from it and meanwhile we could
make money to run this program and to
expand it through getting the carbon
offset costs out of the carbon Market so
it's an educational piece first and
foremost of humans we think that we know
what we're doing with deforestation or
or the way that we plant certain crops
and and the way that we get yields but
really when we're educated by people
that have already went through this
process they can tell us that we can
plant certain crops in in other areas we
can take we can get financial incentives
from non-deforestations yes and that is
really awesome and that can be applied
in so many other places in the world and
of course what we're really doing is
sustainable Community Development the
very thing where my dissertation started
in Highland Guatemala and so I knew
immediately we could not impose a system
we had to come and learn from them
what would work for example we realized
that fish
are very popular
along with unfortunately bush meat all
sorts of wild animals but fish could be
sustainably grown in ponds
so we now have over 40 tilapia ponds
and they're able to eat a wild food but
domesticated which is a transition back
into agriculture the reason why they're
eating wild animals there is after the
war the only people that survived are
the ones that ate wild animals
now they need to transition back into a
more sophisticated form of Agriculture
so tilapia is one of the ways and the
other way is caterpillars
who knew these guys eat three months of
the year they eat caterpillars and so we
planted all the trees that grow these
caterpillars all around the Villages
that were willing to be part of our
conservation project
and now they get free protein a third of
the Year raining out of their of the
trees that are around them so they used
to be in remote places in the rainforest
and it put women and girls at risk to
even to go out there
so we have learned from them the
conditions of their lives we use a
profit motive based system so that they
don't think that we're do-gooder
charitable types they're going to
disappear tomorrow
and we enter in and make a deal you do
this for us we'll do this for you which
they understand perfectly and will
employ quite a few of your best and
brightest to work in our company to make
sure it happens and oh those guys who
are the best hunters we want them as our
forest rangers yeah we want them to hunt
the hunters
and we'll pay them twice whatever they
were making hunting to do so
so that project is going ongoing it's a
little bit on the shelf right now
because we're having political
difficulties in the country but we're
hoping in the long term that will work
and that's why I'm now putting some
energy into this Mongolia one
to say it another way you know you might
ask why am I not continuing to work with
the Mayan people I've learned their
languages I've learned in depth about
them they're kind of doing okay
certainly the one the zapatists are
doing just fine
but I'm in a point at this point with
the condition that the work planet is in
that my feeling is I really need to put
the last of my anthropological entities
energies into trying to save this planet
yeah the sustainable Community
Development right and non-governmental
approach has always been tiny
no scale you know we helped and save the
children we helped nine municipalities
one about the other two thousand
municipalities they're just going to
resent us
right whereas now in these projects
we're talking about large large areas
our Target is 57 million hectares yeah
that you can see from outer space very
clearly totally in Mongolia maybe twice
that maybe a hundred million hectares
yeah right that is a huge amount of land
we're not owning it totally we're just
renting the right to conserve it and get
the the carbon offsets for it which we
cannot get unless we help the people do
it right yes right so we don't get paid
unless we do development right yes and
if we are getting paid we're also saving
the planning yep you follow the
relationship so it's so beautiful so
it's a business model ultimately me the
last person I ever thought the shaman
becomes the businessman
but the business model in essence
incentivizes the right Behavior to scale
yep yep so it's the ultimate sustainable
Community Development at a planetary
scale yo and that's where I've ended up
starting with little family and Highland
Guatemala and old Shaman and an old
midwife
and now I'm trying to save the the
planet these large chunks as I can get
it's the it's so beautiful because it's
the sustainable Community Development
those three words are just they're
perfect stainable Community Development
the more that we can pass that down over
time to children on Earth
the better will be off and I'm really
happy that that you that you're you're
leading this in
um the Democratic Republic of Congo and
then from there Mongolia and then from
there Kazakhstan maybe or there's so
many places in the world where we can do
this I'm really happy that that you're
working on that and I've also trained up
a bunch of students who are helping me
with this and when I go retired to my
black blue elderberry farm in in
Northern California they're all going to
carry it forward so I don't have a
feeling that it was you know my little
One-Shot deal and then it's done and we
have their generation and the following
generation working on sustainable
Community developments give us a quick
bit on the elderberries okay
when I was still uh fairly young and
raising little children
um I I ran into some
Health Food hippie type of guy in Austin
who said if you don't want your kids
bringing colds home from
the daycare
try black elderberry
and so I I went and bought them and made
my own little syrup out of them and gave
them to the kids
I never had colds anymore
and so uh since that time I have used it
myself and have had very few and I have
spread the word to other people because
it's not in the cold section of your
drugstore it's usually in the airplane
travel section or whatever
um you know big Pharma does not want you
to know there's a cure for the common
cold
and uh so my son moved up into a
northern northern Central California in
an area that is basically rednecks and
pot growing hippies
and so I've decided that once I retire
I'm going to move up there as well and
try to bring those two warring
populations together around a
replacement for pot because pot
eventually isn't going to be worth very
much now that it's legal and big
corporations are going to grow vast
quantities of it the price is going to
go down but
I have taught a lot of medical
anthropology along the way and one of
the things I know very well is a it's
all about the immune system
uh because uh
people get diseases when their immune
system is not up to par diseases that
don't kill us like I tested positive for
TB almost every time I came back from
Chiapas but in a few months it was
negative why because I have a really
good immune system because I'm fed well
and I have good exercise and I live
healthy
but in the future as our
Pharmaceuticals are less effective
against evolving bugs
it seems to me where we're going to need
to put more of our emphasis is on a
healthy immune system not drugs that are
going to kill a bug
and it turns out the best comments
plants of the earth yes and who knew
that the best elderberries not the black
elderberry of Europe it's the blue
elderberry that's native to California
it's interesting so I've already got 20
trees up there three years old and
they're starting to produce and the idea
is to be a kind of Johnny Appleseed
of Elderberry which I predict in 10
years will be worth more by the pound
than pot awesome blue Elder blue
elderberries and that will bring the
rednecks and the hippies together
because around health and around
revitalizing the rural Countryside
replacing trees that would burn in in
fires with blue elderberry which is a
bush and doesn't burn very well
you guys heard it here first from Duncan
the blue elderberry and get behind it
get go check it out and get behind it
Duncan whoa this has been super fun fun
for me too yeah I came back an extra day
just to do this oh it's so nice of you
awesome and there's just there's too
much to
unpack about
the sustainable Community developments
what you've learned throughout your time
when you're explaining about how you can
do a temporary segregation to empower
women that's so interesting I see some
of that happening today with our friend
groups there are these these groups of
women that are living together inside of
homes in Santa Cruz and the North Bay in
the Bay Area
and then they get super powerful and
concentrated and then there's no men
there distracting them either you know
sexually or whatever right you're
undermining their Authority exactly all
that kind of stuff so
um I'm actually you know this has been
there's so much good
points that came from this and I'm happy
that you're running those four projects
they're very important projects for
Earth because anthropology is not just
about exotic places far away yeah
anthropology is about all of us on this
planet yeah you know and it's a planet
we need to save and we're not going to
save it if we can't provide sustainable
Community Development for the people who
live on it yeah and lots of the people
in the world have a way lower carbon
footprint than we do like the Mayan
peasants that I lived with yeah well you
know they're ready to save the Earth why
are they ready to save the Earth for
them the Earth is a religious
concern the Earth is a living spiritual
place so when you trash the Earth it's
not just a bad intellectual idea or
against the science of the environment
it's a sin it is and it is a sacred
place and we have to have the proper
stewards of it you know I always say if
you believe in god what about God's
creation
if God is sacred why is God's creation
not sacred
that's a great way to put it and also
once we can get
completely carbon-free forms of energy
potentially things like nuclear fusion
at its absolute optimal we can sustain
on this planet
forever very effectively and even out
into the cosmos
wow such a pleasure thank you pleasure's
all mine show Duncan this has been this
has been super fun everyone go check out
Duncan's links in the bio also check out
check out aaa's links in the bio give us
your comments on the episode we'd love
to hear your thoughts about everything
that we talked about give us your
thoughts go and build the future
manifest your destiny into the world
everyone much love and we'll see you
soon peace bye fellow earthlings see
Earthlings